und 20 gern 15-mal curly freis genau
richtig und dann noch zehnmal diese
kirsch tasche leute und ganz kurzen auch
wir sind mittlerweile 30.000 fordert
eine million deswegen ist für mich mega
freundin den kanal abonniert 50 prozent
von allen leuten ich meine videos sparen
haben dass nämlich noch nicht getan und
ist sehr traurig über deswegen fühle
mich extrem freuen alle vielleicht
abonnieren und jetzt gehts weiter
portisch als gedacht und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja nötig
habe das natürlich geht es gut ist hat
jetzt dezember angefangen und das ist
praktisch auch schon so eine kleine
tradition bei wir hier auf dem kanal die
hamas vor zwei jahren angefangen habe
ich so irgendwie mal 100 euro mcdonald's
monopoly gemacht und letztlich habe ich
es wieder gemacht allerdings nicht so
professionell sein und auch voll
verkauft weil ich das system gar nicht
gecheckt hat deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht wir machen das heute immer
wieder aber ich habe mich so ein
bisschen mehr informiert natürlich und
ich habe mir für diesen september zum
ziel gesetzt man kann also verschiedene
sachen gewinnen wenn man halt viele
straßen hat oder so und ich habe das
letzte ist schon mal angekündigt im
video da habe ich gesagt er war das
video jetzt hinter uns mal machen wir
dieses jahr wieder dick mcdonald's
monopoly und es hat 10.000 knack und mir
auch sehr viele von euch bei instagram
geschrieben dass ich mich irgendwie bei
den melden soll wenn ich so eine straße
oder so weil man kann ja wirklich ganz
coole sachen so gewinnen und wenn mir
dann irgendwas fehlt kann ich das hier
ein video sagen und theoretisch wenn das
irgendwo von euch hat kann es mir zu
schicken und dann schauen wir mal auch
war irgendwie so ein geiles produkt dann
am ende da gewinnen können wir fangen
wird erst mal mit 100 euro
also kaufen wir uns für 100 euro eben
einen bums daheim vor sich jetzt wieder
aufregen so die pommes und so die wir
dann haben wir finden immer einen super
coolen abnehmer kann da ich auch sehr
gerne videos aus dem letzten jahr
anschauen und ja dann würde ich sagen
ich muss meine kreditkarten auf finden
weil er sich eben nicht
damit wir auch bezahlen können keine
wende braucht ihr auch diese map weiß wo
man dann diese straßen kann man kann es
auch online einsehen wohl aber das ist
ja sonst irgendwie besser als ich hab
mich ja wie gesagt schon so ein bisschen
schlau gemacht bei diesen curly freis
die sind eigentlich ganz nice und weil
so ein apfel tranche oder so da gibt es
dann irgendwie so zusätzlich oder das in
mehr sticker drauf als auf anderen
produkten deswegen fangen wir damit an
romano curly frei fund so erdbeer
taschen oder so ich brauche auch selber
neuen computer vielleicht kann man da ja
sowas gewinnen apple iphone 11 50 mal
hier also die chance dass man sowas
gewinnt oder das ich jetzt fahren nur
aufs gewinnen ist natürlich obwohl
vielleicht gar nicht mal so gering weil
ich ja noch ganz viele zuschauer dann
theoretisch mit in dieses straßen
einbinden kann also ich werde diesen
gewinn dann am ende auf keinen fall für
mich selber nicht dass das jetzt hier
irgendwie falsch verstand wird
allerdings oft eine reise oder soja es
gibt auch eine reise ja was machst du da
sie noch nicht vielleicht meine reisen
keine ahnung das ist erst mal angefangen
und dann später darüber nachdenken also
jetzt kauft wir müssen es aber gleich
ist schon dunkel
ich bin mal gespannt wie lange wir heute
warten müssen weil das dauert und immer
so ein bisschen bis man die sachen
kriegt ne aber ist sie leer aus
ich denke sie zur seite jetzt muss ich
erstmal den überzeugen dass ich wirklich
das ernst meint das ist eine große
bestellung ist ein bisschen größere
bestellung und zweite ich gern 15-mal
curly preis genau richtig und dann noch
zehnmal diese kirsch tasche und können
sie mit diesen dieses monopol ist dazu
geben nämlich anschuldigung noch einmal
fünfmal kreis oben drauf und dann ist
dann reicht ja ja genau das nicht
verstanden dann sagst du noch mal und
hat das eine klappe diesem blatt
alles gedanken dann geschönt haben also
aber es war nicht die größte bestellung
ich habe schon meine größte tätig hier
soll ich jetzt nicht zur seite dann
fahren wir sind auch unter den 100 euro
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich
glaube dass man jetzt irgendwas mit 80
aber es reicht auf jeden fall erstmal
mit anfangen dann fahre ich noch mal
machen zweiten partner gibt es am 20
ja genau wenn beides nämlich beide ja
danke dass sie braucht doch oder
das ist aber das bleibt was da unten
drunter ist hat ein bisschen gedauert
also warten
jetzt müssen wir 20 minuten war das
check ich halt wirklich erst jetzt ist
halt wie normales monopoly du brauchst
halt zum beispiel eine volle straße oder
alle vier bahnhöfe und dann hast du
schon was geworden muss man nur mal
schauen was man gewonnen hat was ist
wenn man das ganze set voll hat dann
habe ich hier das dann dank gehört im
mcdonald's wahrscheinlich oder neuer
besitzer dafür habe ich ja auch meine
zuschauer können sich einmal ein
bisschen aufklären und ich habe richtig
lust mir sagen hier richtig klick auf
dieses jahr was ist so das gesamtbudget
für die ganze für die ganzen folgen die
ich dann mache dass ich irgendwas
gewonnen
300 euro heute ging eigentlich flock so
ich würde mal sagen ja nicht mal zehn
minuten gewartet hat jetzt wie gesagt so
irgendwann mit 80 euro gekostet ich weiß
nicht genau
und wir haben jetzt hier wirklich zwei
fette tüten stellen wir vor meinte man
kriegt eine von diesen richtig dicken
typen damit komplett carry trades voll
eigentlich schon dass diese komplett
voll leute genug gelagert wir sehen uns
das gleich zu hause mit dass ausgepackt
und wir schauen mal opfer von irgendwas
irgendwie in der richtung kommen dass
man irgendwie die chance etwas zu
gewinnen keine ahnung ich muss mich ja
erstmal rein finden in dieses ganze
system hier also wisst gar nicht
gestellt
der film besticht sollte vielleicht
kommen wir sind jetzt ehrlich da hier
das licht beiden großen typen von girlie
frei ok und hier habe ich mir noch
diesen monopoly boden geben nach dass
man halt jeder an sondern übersicht hat
und ich frage mich gerade als wenn man
diese drei straßen hat hat man dann
sofort eine iphone gewonnen weil das so
dann könnte ich jetzt sagen ey wer von
euch hat hauptstraße wer von euch wird
rathausplatz werden wenn euch
albanusstraße schicken wir da irgendwie
dann möglichst sein oder vielleicht auch
nicht wir fangen jetzt einfach erstmal
an
ich pack das mal aus aber mal nachzählen
ob es auch wirklich 20 sind zumal ich
glaube nämlich auf diesen curly fraser
hat zum beispiel drei sticker drauf und
auf pommes werden halt nur zwei ja und
dann haben wir diese genau hier kannst
du mir nur einen euro und hier haben wir
auch immer zwei sogar drei aber auch 23
privaten wir dann vielleicht sind immer
zwei das in immer zwei entscheide dann
spielst du das jetzt schon ja ich bin
wieder raus aus dem monopoly das ist
natürlich so dass pro tag sozusagen habe
ich gerade sagen haben wir jetzt genug
fürs nächste jahr sollte das allerdings
das so ausdrücken was mir passieren
wichtig ist auf der autofahrt niemand
wirklich niemand
alex einmal bis 20 kirschen sind ja auch
nicht geilenkirchen
ich glaube das fand ich die nicht geil
wir mittlerweile hier mal alles
ausgepackt
ich muss sagen so katie price und süß
sauer richtig punktzahl im frontend fand
jetzt einfach mal schnell an und dann
können wir gleich schauen warum hast du
so friedvoll das mühldorfer wir haben
hier direkt poststraße und max an der
sofort gewinnen das heißt ich weiß diese
poststraße jetzt mal ab sofort gewinnen
kommt alles in irgendeine tiefe und
jetzt fehlt hier wohl noch die
elisenstraße und chausseestraße und dann
hat man ich weiß nicht ob man die chance
darauf hat oder ob man wirklich wenn uns
ein bild einer mexiko reise für zwei
personen von urlaubs grube bekommt ich
glaub du musst also kannst ja aufkleben
nun ja da muss man es wahrscheinlich
hinschicken
und du hast dann glaube ich die chance
das zu gewinnen dann fühle ich einfach
komplett alles aus und dann muss hier
irgendwas gewinnen vielleicht kriegt
hier auf doppelt wenn die leute was zu
schlichten bahnhofstraße und jackpot
corner diesen jackpot kann ich auch noch
vom letzten jahr
den braucht man aber nicht erscheinen
schlossallee und nordbahnhof und mal
können wir beides gebrauchen und
sofortgewinnen einen kaffee oder
cappuccino zeitgleich für so ins auto
legen die soziale anders lieber hof
einer schon zwei bahnhöfe und münchener
straße aber die chance dass man dann
wirklich was gewinnt ich weiß nicht also
chausseestraße cook es wird noch eine
straße dann haben ja schon im vollen
straßen reihe
na ja und jetzt brauchen wir nicht
goethestraße und nochmal neue straße
scheiße theaterstraße und kommen sofort
gewinnen sollte von den sachen die ich
doppelt habe wenn das irgendwann von
euch unbedingt braucht ihr könnt mir
sehr gerne bei instagram schreiben ich
kann jetzt schon sagen dass ich nicht
alles lesen werde aber ihr könnt es sehr
gern versuche ich schau mal rein und
wenn dann irgendwer unbedingt noch eine
straße war um irgendwas falls haben
ständig vielleicht dann rum so per brief
sofortgewinnen eistüte software und
münchner straße wir haben das ja schon
mal voll beklebt wie viele haben das
gefühl nein wir haben es nicht gemacht
weil wir es nicht gereicht haben dass
man das machen kann ich meinte wir haben
schon mal so ein ding also ich habe
schon mal geklickt habe es noch nicht
gemacht ich glaube ich habe deine
aufgeklebt das ganze affäre fährt viel
gefehlt dann
also wir haben auf jeden fall warte mal
ich hab noch eine andere theorie so
jetzt zum beispiel wenn man mir diese
straßen hat münchner straße wiener
straße und berliner straße die drei
baumann münchner und wiener straße habe
jetzt schon doppelt kann ja sein dass
diese berliner straße halb voll selten
ist so jetzt hab ich hier schon wieder
münchner straße habe er schon viermal
wir haben jetzt schon nordbahnhof
südbahnhof und hauptbahnhof goethestraße
und bachstraße badstraße habe ich noch
nicht gilt straße habe ich schon ja
jungen wie das ruhig die ganze welt als
super noch neun wochen war es fehlt noch
was fehlt noch auf bahnhof nordbahnhof
südbahnhof und wieder schloss an ich
glaube das ist halt wirklich so dass
manche halt extrem selten sind die
braucht man dann um irgendwas gewinnen
zu können
sechseinhalb stunden später wie oft
wollen wir ändern da essen gehen dass
man als zeichner otto normalverbraucher
der jetzt nicht solche dummen videos
hier dreht da eine chance hat irgendwas
zu gewinnen da muss ja täglich da sein
oder nicht gibt sogar ein beitrag auf
also in doku beiträge hab ich mal
gesehen wurde familie das wirklich
gemacht hat und haben die das gewand ich
glaube tatsächlich gut wir machen auch
ein logo beitragen und unsere ist viel
professioneller schon bescheid gesagt zu
meistern weiß ich das klappt zu obwohl
die ersten vier schauen so wir haben das
alles erklärt ich wollte mal kurz zu mir
diese erdbeertorte probieren die
probleme es gut obwohl es vielleicht ein
bisschen künstlich na ja auf jeden fall
so sieht das fällt jetzt aus sicherheits
markus in die kamera du kannst ja mal
drüber gehen und ich habe jetzt
praktisch für 80 euro gegessen und wir
haben wirklich nicht eine straße
komplett voll weil meine vermutung war
ja auch schon dass bestimmte straßen
halt extrem selten sind ihr könnt mich
gerne in den kommentaren darüber
aufklären wenn ihr das genauer wissen
ansonsten wenn jemand von euch die
hauptstraße hat oder die parkstraße oder
den westbahn wo dann schreib mir auf
jeden fall auf in spa und schickt mir
bitte ein foto davon so schreibe einfach
in den ersten kommentar die sachen die
gefilmt wurde
wenn irgendwas davon habt nur auf
dienstag schickt mir ein foto nach vorn
weil ich wer sonst
von diesen zwölf irgendwelche durchgehen
wenn ich irgendwie sowas sagen wenn ich
dann kommt so ein foto wo einerseits
diese sozusagen gut ansonsten wir machen
weiter und wir schauen mal am ende ob
wir das ding in voll kriegen ich bin
echt gespannt also leute bleibt update
dezember gibt es jeden tag ein neues
video das war's lasst doch nach oben da
abonniert den kanal und wir sehen uns
morgen 19 uhr
da gibt es dann wieder ein etwas
lehrreiches video kann man das
vielleicht zu sagen also der haut bei
instagram alex w